we're continuing our conversation with
Scott Adams author of many many books as
well as the creator of the Dilbert comic
strip and increasingly a sort of
political social critic of sorts I would
say is that do you see yourself that way
well I'm an observer and I like to talk
about persuasion in politics more than
more than that just naked politics of it
my book when Bigley is about persuasion
and president Trump's persuasion in
particular and I try to put that filter
on everything from the economy to
immigration to the rest of the stuff so
to pick up where we left off we were
talking about the tax plan of the
president and we can sort of continue
there or or look at tariffs which I know
we have to look at sort of separately
but to go back to the sort of main
thread that I was pointing to you the
I'm I'm not seeing the ways in which we
can link those policies to what we would
call a strong and robust economy beyond
your assertion that you made in part one
that we may have expected to see a
drop-off in the economic indicators as
we moved away from the bottom of a
recession it's a bit arbitrary to say
that that should have already happened I
mean maybe it were a year from that
maybe we're three years from that the
the question that I'm pointing to more
is what can we really say empirically
about the policy of Donald Trump that
proves to us that he has kept that going
other than just saying well it hasn't
moved the indicators one way or the
other
yeah when you're talking about politics
and you're talking about economics in
particular there are a lot of variables
and I don't think you didn't ever get to
the point of yeah he did this and so
that caused that
okay I have to sort of look at all the
variables and the after you ask yourself
are they the right decisions and if they
seem right sort of in you know in the
abstract are we seeing a set of results
that would be consistent with making
right decisions so for example we would
imagine that cutting taxes would have a
good psychological benefit and we
observed that the consumer confidence is
at
we're sky-high I think they may have
pulled back a little bit because of the
stock market but in general we saw that
it was a decision they should have
worked
meaning it should have been good for the
economy and then we see that the economy
is good that's different from saying it
caused it well but I think it's also not
I think you're assuming a lot by merely
saying a tax cut increases confidence in
the economy it depends who gets the tax
cut right because if people who are very
wealthy a get a tax cut and we know that
because of the diminishing marginal
value a utility of $1 they're mostly
saving that money I don't know why again
unless the average middle-class person
is an adherent of supply-side economics
why the average middle-class person
would say I'm more confident in the
economy because Scott Adams got a tax
cut for example well the people are
getting tax cuts typically are the ones
starting businesses they're they're
responsible for the largest part of
economic activity so what we you would
expect is that you would expect that it
would work exactly the way it played out
but your question is more to the
psychology no I don't think it is
because here's where I think we actually
disagree on the way that the tax cut
works if you give someone who is already
very wealthy for example a tax cut
number one the economic theory of the
diminishing marginal utility of money
means that a thousand dollars to them is
a far smaller value or utility than a
thousand dollars to someone who makes
thirty thousand dollars would we at
least both agree with that piece yeah of
course we would
additionally the person for whom that
thousand dollars is not really worth
very much is not as likely to spend that
money as the person who earns $30,000
it's much more likely they would just
put that money in a bank account it's
almost like a rounding error for them
they wouldn't even really notice it is
do we agree with that piece yes we do
and based on the concept of economic
multipliers we know that someone putting
a thousand dollars in a saving account
is not nearly as good for the economy by
several orders
magnitude as someone taking that
thousand dollars and spending it at the
grocery store and on a new car and on a
vacation would we agree with that piece
of it you're saying a dollar spent on
expense is better than a dollar invested
I'm saying that saving money in a bank
account is not stimulative in the way
that for example supporting local
businesses by buying products and
services is yes okay I agree so
therefore don't we have to come to the
conclusion that simply giving a tax cut
to rich people is not this obviously
great thing for the economy here's the
psychology part of that okay what what
are all of the major news organizations
reporting about the tax cut because I'm
pretty sure that the news the you know
the professionals who essentially assign
opinions to the public okay it's the
public doesn't the public doesn't have
an independent opinion about the economy
they're you know very few of them have
any kind of background in which that
would make any sense that's fair so for
for economics and politics and you know
any of the big questions in life our
opinions are assigned to us by the
people on television and the people in
the news the you know the opinion makers
and the opinion makers are pretty well
agreed that tax cuts are stimulative so
it almost doesn't matter that giving tax
cuts to rich people is not stimulative
in the way that giving a middle-class
tax cut is if people believe that it is
then what people go and spend money they
don't actually have because they think
tax cuts for rich people are good in
general optimism drives the economy
would you agree with that statement well
I think that optimism by those who are
controlling whether the Dow goes up or
down does drive the economy but I'm not
sure I've seen any evidence that you
know some oh who makes $37,000 a year
being optimistic actually drives the
economy before just getting Joe to make
some bad decisions and going into credit
card debt so in order in order for the
economy to grow people have to think
that next year is going to be better
than this year so
that they will invest so in the investor
class there are people who are investing
who maybe would not have otherwise just
because of the psychology of it they've
been told a tax cuts now tax cuts we're
talking at it like it's an isolated
thing if everything depended on tax cuts
I'm not sure that would even be enough
of a variable to move move the world but
we're also talking about a bigger story
of regulations being cut frankly I can't
mention it I can't think of one
regulation specifically they got caught
that makes any real-world difference but
as long as the president's talking about
it and people think that matters that
maybe it does I don't know then that's
another piece of information this has
optimism you see him negotiating with
other countries we'll talk about that
more yeah that makes people think oh
that's a good thing that's somebody who
knows what they're doing they're playing
tough might might be a little pain in
the short-run but but it shouldn't work
out so the president has embarked on a
package of influence if you will that
collectively makes the average person
think huh I think things are going in
the right direction
why does when we have a thirty eight
percent if it's the average person who
thinks things are going well why does
why is his approval rating thirty eight
percent well his approval rating is not
based on the economy alone if it were I
suppose we'd get different numbers by
the way it is always one of the most
important elements for figuring out
whether you think the president's doing
a good job self-reported people the
economy is a top issue dude do you have
you know the stats off and I don't of
how many people approve of the
president's economics not that not
offhand it's a bit higher right I'm not
50 percent right so if you can get any
politician in this country to get a
forty to fifty percent approval on
anything in in the year 2019 that's
really good
right because we have such a team sport
to thing going on that game nobody's
going to get seventy percent approval on
anything anymore those days are gone so
if you're telling me the president only
got 40 percent or only got 50 percent of
approval on a specific thing my
immediate reaction is that's probably
about as good
you can do I guess that makes it all the
more amazing that when you say to people
do you think the government has a duty
to provide some basic level of health
care regardless of ability to pay it's
amazing that there's more than 70% on
that isn't it Oh health care I'm a
critic of the president yeah I was
nothing you weren't I was I'm just
saying that it's amazing that there's
actually seven seventy percent is all
that more amazing when you consider that
well here's here's what's amazing about
that number
it's amazing that the Republicans don't
have a plan even a bad plan
just any kind of a frickin plan is I
would say it's unforgivable I mean it's
it's just it's horrible so I'm just I'm
a strong critic of that that that is one
of the few cases where we could all
agree and I think the the 70% gets to
the fact that nobody's got an idea how
to fix this you know but everybody wants
it fixed
I had a whole bunch of other stuff to
ask about politically but we're sort of
short on time so one thing I wanted to
mention is this morning you tweeted that
the shutdown is a Nancy Pelosi tantrum
and that she can't let Trump win I'm
curious about that I mean if if one
believes that the wall is the wrong way
to spend money and is ineffective why
should she give the guy money for it and
as far as it being a Pelosi tantrum talk
about what you mean by that because
Trump said he would shut it down and he
did how does that make it a Pelosi
tantrum I don't get that well that was a
Twitter comment which of course are
always a little bit of hyperbole but
I'll give you the more legitimate answer
all right both both Pelosi and Trump
have the power to open the government
all they have to do is give the other
one whatever it is that they want so
it's not one person closed the
government both of them have to disagree
with the other side so it's it's kind of
a tie no no no that is not it that is
not fair if I if there's a negotiation a
divorce negotiation and one party I know
you don't like analogies but I'll make
one and one party goes to the other and
says hey listen I want 99 percent of the
of all of your future earnings
and the other party says no I'm not
going to do that well here's why I don't
like you Bella juice you you you've said
that because they weren't able to agree
they're equally responsible but that's
not actually the case
Donald Trump said I will shut it down if
I don't get money for the wall and and
that's what he wanted and that that's
not there's no expectation that he's
supposed to get what he wants
well keep in mind that we have two sides
that are actually in complete agreement
so if like your analogy of the married
couple are getting divorced they're in
disagreement so so in that case one of
them could actually be to blame for any
impasse because they're disagree okay
both Republic Republicans and Democrats
have agreed that engineers they don't
say these words and they should but
engineers need to decide where do you
put a fence where do you put some drones
where do you put more of a solid
structure or is it more sensible and
economical and does it meet the specs
better to put a steel slapped structure
you know I think you would agree that
Democrats at least the Pelosi types are
not open borders people they would like
a a competent border security and in the
past they have been okay with very
various fancy you know wall like
structures and have even funded them as
fairly as recently so to imagine that
these two groups have an actual
disagreement I I don't think you can
claim that in any genuine sense no it's
not okay I think you can because and I
think here's why I'm not an open borders
person I don't think that there is
actually the immigration crisis that
Trump and some on the right describe and
now the reasons why are number one we
have a net outflow of undocumented
immigrants to Mexico number two
economically we know that undocumented
immigrants are paying into welfare
systems they will never get benefits
back out of number three undocumented
immigrants commit crime at lower rates
than american-born citizens so it's not
that I can't figure out what it is that
the border should be engineers slats or
concrete or whatever it's that
I think this is a solution to a problem
that has been blown up 2/3 of
undocumented immigrants are here on
overstayed visas so I think that Nancy
Pelosi's position is not in coherent
that she doesn't think we should have
open borders but she thinks 25 billion
in total or five billion initially for
this wall is not a good idea I think
that's coherent which which part of that
do you think Trump disagrees with he
believes that this is an acute crisis he
believes that undocumented immigrants
commit crimes at higher rates than
american-born citizen I mean I think he
disagrees with almost everything wait
wait wait wait wait wait let's take one
at a time
you you think he thinks that
american-born
people who were not documented commit
crimes a higher rate than the rest of
citizens no not american-born people I'm
talking about he said many times that
the the sort of criminal Kara character
is how he has described undocumented
immigrants and the data there was not my
opinion Yeah right behold on I don't
believe he's given conflicting data with
that when I hear the Republican opinion
on this which by the way I don't
completely you know buy into that side
of the opinion okay but when I hear in
the opinion what I hear is why would why
would we let one crime in if we could
prevent it that's not an adult way to
actually think about it right this is
sort at any time that government has to
establish or law enforcement has to
establish a system for dissuading an
action that we don't want you can always
say let's go to the next level and next
level until zero people are the ones
that are doing this thing that we don't
want done but at a certain point you do
have to evaluate what is the cost and
what is the benefit I don't think that's
crazy right I mean if the wall were to
cost 200 billion to prevent a hundred
people from crossing illegally would we
still be saying that it's worth it no we
wouldn't know yeah so at a certain point
we have let's say okay well let me five
billion when there is a net outflow what
is the limit is the question what
well the your your giving me lots of
different topics I want to I want at
least drill down and any one of them
sure the the question about the net
outflows doesn't get to the fact that
there are you know a number of people
can be and that cause problems
sure and wouldn't it be better if they
could all come in but under a legal
system where we know who it is and we
make sure they're part of the process
that's fair you remember that the the
Republican point of view is not stop
people from coming in that that's not
the view the view is can't we find a way
to force them to come in Legally so that
the system is working for them the same
way it's working for the citizens yeah
the most sanitized version that we've
sometimes heard but then when we
remember well we want people from Norway
rather than [ __ ] countries and
they're not sending their best they're
sending criminals and rapists and some
I'm sure are good people and two
theories are not reviews but hold on
hold on and two-thirds are not actually
crossing the border I don't know how all
of that gets us to the solutions a
twenty five billion dollar wall but let
me just pick off your worst part of
thinking in that statement the fact that
the fact that the vast majority of
people come in if through overstayed
visas is not in any way connected to
whether you should you should have good
border security because the fact that
you know somebody might burglarize my
home doesn't stop me from not wanting to
be mugged in my car I mean they're just
different things they're just they're
not in the sense that if what we're
trying to do is to most quickly and most
efficiently get ourselves to the fewest
number of undocumented immigrants in the
country you would deal with the worst
problem first and it just so happens
that the one that represents two-thirds
rather than one-third could be dealt
with in ways that would be far less
controversial and much easier
politically to deal with wait are you
saying that there's an easy solution to
the 2/3 visa overstays I'm not saying
it's an easy solution but what I am
saying is that it would be much
political
how about you're saying there's no
solution so you have one big problem the
V
overstays and one smaller problem the
smaller problem has in the opinion of
Republicans a reasonably normal obvious
way to fix it which is improving border
security you can argue about the
technique the visa overstays to the best
of my knowledge doesn't have a solution
why do you think that is why do you
think knowing the hole let me there
might be but let me finish the thought
there in no way would you not solve the
smaller problem that you can solve just
because there exists a problem you can
solve elsewhere that makes no sense at
all
no I think that the characterization of
that argument implies that because we
haven't seen a focus politically on the
two-thirds that we just don't know how
to do it that the the reasons are
political the wall is something that is
a sort of metaphor for Trump being
strong and Republicans being strong
saying instead we're gonna focus on what
is actually the bigger problem here it's
not a winner politically there's no
imagery associated with it that's
beneficial for Trump to say we're gonna
I guess focus more on enforcing
overstayed visas it's not sexy that's
why they're not talking about it I think
they're not talking about it because
nobody has a suggestion now if you have
really how come we don't know it it's
the biggest problem in immigration and
neither of us have even heard a
suggested solution but I haven't heard
are you saying that the reason we
haven't heard of how to deal with that
is simply that no one has any ideas it's
because politically there's no benefit
to talking about it I think that's a
stretch because this used to be you you
think if the president couldn't easily
solve two-thirds of the illegal
immigration problem you think he
wouldn't do it there's no benefit to the
imagery and an image that he wants to
develop by talking about this wall he's
the Builder Mexico will pay for it that
is politically beneficial in a way that
dealing with the not sexy two-thirds of
overstayed visas is simply not that's
just the reality now that's another
reality those are two separate problems
one has an obvious solution and one
doesn't that's all I see
okay well III also don't think that the
wall is the obvious solution I think
it's it's not a good solution but I
don't think we're gonna agree on that at
that element of this either oh no way
we're not disagreeing on the wall I
think the wall I think you would agree
we need some border security and that
you and I and politicians are not the
ones to decide where do you put a wall
where do you put electronic surveillance
would you agree we're probably under
exactly the same I think that the idea
I've seen you float this idea that quote
engineers should decide this is more
than just do you use see-through slats
or concrete and how many miles do you
build Engineers can certainly make
recommendations on that they can't weigh
the cost of that versus the benefit and
the political alternatives that also
exist I think it's fine to ask engineers
about rebar versus concrete but I don't
think engineers Ellucian here no
engineers do look at the economics so
they would look at all the solutions so
they don't just make materials decisions
they are primarily in the job of what's
the best way to make it work to your
specifications the specifications would
include being able to see through it
which might lead them toward a medal of
you know a steel solution instead of
concrete and that would be fine okay but
whether you can see through the porter
wall or not doesn't tell us in the
context of the number of people that are
coming in what this would cost in total
and all of the other considerations
whether it should be done at all well
they're they're going to start with the
specs and the specifications would be
something like we have to see through it
we have to be able to build it in these
places and it should stop you know
ninety percent of the people who might
try to get over it so that something
like that would be the specs and then
the engineers would say okay best way to
do that is steel slats or concrete or in
these places we don't need it just put
some fence there you know Israel's wall
is mostly fence a lot of people don't
know that so and and in Israel the
decision about where to put a wall and
where to put a fence has more to do with
how much width you have on the border to
work with if you have a lot of space
than a fence with
you know like travelling means and stuff
works great but is let's say you're in a
populated area where you don't have
enough space to build you know on either
side of the wall and the wall sort of
your default
yeah but Scott doesn't what this doesn't
tell us is whether we should be working
on the wall versus something totally
different altogether in dealing with
this problem or others that's the point
I'm trying to make it I don't think it's
even really a controversial one well but
but but that's like saying why would we
work on the wall when people are still
getting speeding tickets they're just
different why don't you so they're not
at all because local police know there
is a limited amount that's local police
departments work on speeding tickets and
how to set speed limits when it comes to
federal government priorities there is
some limit both to the amount of
legislative time political capital and
funding uuugh grant that that's
different than just saying people speed
in Boston so why are we talking about a
wall I rest my case
that analogies never persuade anybody
that's my enough as my analogy
completely failed because you just pick
out the differences and and focus on
them yes the point is make some of your
own of your analogy I guess all right so
but the point is the immigration is a
big topic yeah but you can get into
subtopics people coming across people
doing visa overstays because you don't
have a solution for one part of it yes
is it no way evidence or logical it does
not logically suggest that you should
not solve the part you can't solve and
and that's actually the argument I'm
hearing and my mind just goes but I hear
that because there's just no connective
tissue to that thought I resolve the
problems consult well I think that we
would only be continuing to disagree on
the same point so let's wrap up with
just one last thing which is Mexico is
obviously not paying for the wall right
not an idiot away that I can see though
no okay
well it's always nice to end on a point
of agreement scott adams creator of the
world famous Dilbert comic strip if i
was ever written into the comic strip as
a character
even as a horrible person it would still
be an incredible thing and maybe someday
we will see that Scott Adams always
great to talk to you all right great to
talk to you thanks for thanks for this
conversation